and the Baltimore Sun says the statue of
you as chief justice Roger tawny was
removed from the Maryland State House
grounds overnight tawny wrote the
Supreme Court's notorious Dred Scott
decision which upheld slavery there are
an estimated 1500 Confederate symbols on
display in the United States more than
half a dozen of them and at least four
states have been taken down since
Saturday's violence in Charlottesville
Virginia proposals have been made to
remove several others and one of them is
George's Stone Mountain America's
largest Confederate monument Manuel
Bojorquez is there with the renewed
debate over its future Manuel good
morning good morning the entire carved
surface of Stone Mountain spans three
acres and is larger than Mount Rushmore
it depicts three Confederate leaders
robert e lee Jefferson Davis and
Stonewall Jackson there are now renewed
calls to change that across the country
Confederate statues are being pulled
down hoisted up and driven away but a
Georgia stone mountain removing this
Confederate Memorial is a bit more
complicated what you look at that
carving what do you see I see three
white men on horses still fighting a
battle that was ended 140 years ago
Edward Williams is one of hundreds
petitioning to remove or alter the
massive monument the images and the
monuments and statues or representation
of individuals that want it to maintain
and keep a way of life that treated
african-americans as non citizens and we
want those images removed from public
spaces but how could you remove this
though well we can remove it the same
way it was placed there using the stone
cutters the mountain is considered the
birthplace of the modern Ku Klux Klan
more than a century ago it's also where
white supremacist clashed with counter
protesters in 2015 but controversy
hasn't stopped it from becoming the
state's most visited attraction that
even includes a laser light show
we understand the sensitivities of the
carving John Bankhead is with the Stone
Mountain Memorial Association any
changes to the park would have to come
through the state legislature and a
change in the law do you see that
happening in the near future no I don't
bertram Hayes Davis is the great-great
grandson of Confederate President
Jefferson Davis while he believes
Confederate monuments should be removed
from public spaces
he thinks differently about Stone
Mountain because of the significance of
that sculpture as an artwork I think
that it appeases a lot of people to look
at that and I think it should remain
where it is one person urging people to
move past the monuments debate is Civil
Rights icon Andrew Young who feels there
are bigger battles still this remains a
rallying point for hate groups as self
proclaimed KKK member filed a request
for a permit to burn a cross on top of
the mountain in October it was denied
Nora alright man well thank you